welcome back to cbs mornings it's now
been a year since the last u.s troops
left afghanistan after 20 years of war
but even though the fighting has ended
there are still outbreaks of violence
including a suicide bomb attack outside
the russian embassy in kabul this
morning at least three people were
killed including two embassy staff our
mts taeb recently returned to the
country and visited a village that was
caught in the crossfire during the war
he met some of the afghans who are
struggling to recover from the conflict
the streets of wardak province are
bustling again less than an hour's drive
from kabul this taliban stronghold saw
little of the progress and freedoms the
capital did during the two decades of
america's longest war
trapped in the crossfire were villages
like this one dagbagri which today looks
like ancient ruins but what happened
here is a pain still felt by those who
once called it home
it's hard to imagine just 20 years ago
at the start of the war this was a
thriving village full of families but it
quickly became a front line between the
taliban and u.s forces
the village was destroyed
and everyone left
except for marshall the only remaining
resident
the fighting here must have been so
intense for such devastation
oh darcy that was jungkook
yes the fighting was very intense here
he says bullets hit every house u.s
tanks would stop on the main road and
shoot at our houses
in the bitter battles between the
thalabon and us forces ordinary families
were all too often caught in the
fighting or accused of supporting the
taliban the harsh tactics used by some
u.s forces and their afghan allies in
raids across rural afghanistan
are well documented the killings as well
as a lack of accountability drove many
people living in these areas to support
the taliban in a village nestled in this
valley menagedin says he was arrested in
a night raid by u.s forces 12 years ago
he tells us three of his sons were shot
dead as they slept we can't confirm his
account but it's been consistent down
the years and american raids were common
in this area
what did they ask you what did they say
to you
when the americans arrested me that
night they asked where the taliban were
he says i told them i had no connections
with them i asked if they had any proof
that i had met the taliban and they had
no answer
so basically your sons were killed
because of a mistake they
came to the wrong house
when they couldn't prove it they started
asking me why i didn't support the
government more he says i kept asking
how should i cooperate more
who do you blame for your son's killing
america
we blame americans he says why did they
kill innocent people
by 2015 u.s forces left bordak to the
afghan army this abandoned base now
flies the taliban flag after its
takeover one year ago a remnant of the
recent past that still haunts those who
call this area home for cbs morning's
impiaz taya wardak province afghanistan
powerful reporting by mts taeyab